WOLTERSTORFF: Good to be back. Good to
be back at Yale and teach-
ing this course once again on this really
important topic.
And
I'll assume that nothing much has
changed in the ethos of Yale students
in the ten years since I re-- not quite ten
years since I retired, so that you're still feisty
and you have...
disagreements.
So the description for today's seminar that
I was sent
opposes two quite different though related
questions.
One is this:
Do religious people have good reasons to
support pluralistic democracy?
Or to quote the precise words of the description,
"How can we encourage adherents of exclusive
faith traditions
to affirm the political project of liberal--
pluralistic democracy?"
And the other question that I--
that was in the
description I got
was this:
What is the role of religious reasons in public
political debate
within a pluralistic democracy?
Or in the precise words of the description:
"For what reasons and under what conditions
should democratic citizens appeal to matters
of religious faith
in public discourse?"
I trust
you see, as I saw,
the difference between those two questions.
The first asks whether religious people have
good reasons
to support a certain kind of political structure,
namely pluralist, liberal
democracy.
The second assumes the existence of a
religiously
pluralistic democracy,
and it asks what should be the role of religious
reasons within
such a democracy
in public debate about
political issues.
Both of those--
support for the structure, and reasons were
political debate within the structure--
are important.
Both are huge.
The sensible thing for me would be to choose
one of the two and talk only about it, but
I've chosen today not to be sensible,
and to say something about each of them.
In the order.
Of mention.
What I say on the first is going to overlap
interestingly with some things Miroslav said, and
we did not coordinate this.
So start with the first:
Little bit of really quick
brisk history.
Liberal or pluralistic democracy emerged in
the West out of the breakdown of Christendom.
And what was Christendom?
Well, Christendom didn't assume a religiously unified
society.
Specifically, it assumed a society in which
everybody was Christian, in which everybody
was baptized.
Of course
(parenthesis)
everybody knew
that here in there with in Europe there were
people who were not baptized--
in particular Jews. Not only, but
in particular.
But the theory did not take
account of their presence,
with the result, as you know,
that the position of Jews was not only theoretically
anomalous, they were often politically precarious.
They had no
clear position in the structure
unlike the Millets in Islam.
Now, given a society of Christians, the basic
idea of Christendom
was this: that this
religiously unified society-- that's a crucial
part of it-- that this religiously unified society
had two rules
as they were standardly called-- two rules, two
governances:
both being
manifestations of
God's rule.
One rule was that of the church
and one rule was that of the empire.
And since both were over the same people,
the differentiation between these two roles
could not be by reference to the subjects,
but had to be by reference to the aspects
of
peoples'
lives that these two rules
governed, right? So
one people but
two different rules over different aspects of their lives.
So it was a division of powers
rather than a division of
subjects.
Often it was said that the church ruled over
the spiritual life of the people
and that the empire ruled over the secular
life of the people.
The latter--
that the empire rules over the secular life--
was by no means interpreted to mean
that the empire stayed out of moral and religious
matters.
It was on the concrete--to the best of my knowledge--
universally agreed
that it was the duty of the emperor-- the ruler--
to cultivate morality and true religion
in the people.
And not just to cultivate.
To enforce.
Now, as you would guess,
there were all kinds of hassles
over what sect-- over what the spiritual-
secular division
came from, so
Western Christendom was filled with hassles
on that score and-- and by and large they were
settled less by
theoretical acuity than by who had the appropriate
power at the moment.
So you got the picture?
A religiously unified people
under these two rules.
And I think it was pretty clearly the break-up of
the Western church--
oh the Eastern,
Eastern Europe,
I'd have to say different things about it, sorry.
So it was the break-up of the Western church
in the fifteen hundreds that eventually caused
the collapse of Christendom and forced Europe
to rethink
its political structure and the relation between
that
and religion.
At first it experimented with
little Christendoms,
many Christendoms.
Germany would be a Lutheran Christendom,
Spain would continue to be a Catholic Christendom,
Switzerland would be a reform
Christendom, Scotland would be a Presbyterian
Christendom, and
England would be an Anglican Christendom,
and so forth.
But. Very soon
religious diversity got inside of all these
many Christendoms,
and that idea of Christendom became impossible;
both maxi and mini forms became
impossible as a--
political structure.
Well, to take enormous leaps:
after centuries of confusion, ferment, and bloodshed,
there eventually emerged,
towards the end of the seventeen hundreds
the American experiment
of liberal
pluralistic
democracy.
There was a lot of stuff in between,
so it's not just out of the blue.
It was--
I think we tend to forget--
a radical and a risky experiment.
Much about it had never been tried before,
and in particular,
nothing like the relation between religion
and the state,
that the constitutional founders proposed,
had ever been tried before.
So here is
the central question:
And what was the new proposed relation between
the religions of the people
and the state,
the American state?
I think we can probably summarize it in the
following four structural
principles.
First,
church and state are to be distinct
institutions.
Synagogue and the state,
mosque and the state. You get the point.
There's to be a distinction, a clear distinction between
ecclesiastical religious institutions and the state.
Of course,
as I've just observed,
there had long been such a distinction in the West.
So this was not an
innovation on the part of the American founders;
they were
carrying on
what they knew from their Western antecedents
of clear institutional distinctions
between church and state. Second--
that was the first--
the second important structural principle was
freedom of religious exercise.
The state is to
not govern
how people
exercise their religion.
Third,
the state
when distributing benefits and burdens
is not to differentiate in its treatment
of citizens
on account of their religion or lack
thereof. I'm going to say it again:
the state, in its distribution of benefits
and burdens,
is not to discriminate
among its citizens
on the basis of their religion
or lack thereof.
It is going to discriminate on some other bases
but it's not to discriminate
on that basis.
And here's a fourth principle.
Fourth, there is to be no differentiation among citizens
in their right to hold office in the state
and
in their right to--
to a political voice
in the conduct of the personnel of the state.
No discrimination among people on the basis
of their religion as to whether you can hold
office,
or whether you've got voice in
electing
people for
positions in the state.
What do you think? I think those four principles,
structural principles about
the relation of religion and the state,
are essential to the very idea
of a liberal
pluralistic democracy.
You can have a
democracy in the absence of those four principles,
in the sense that you can have people voting
for positions in the
regime and so forth,
but you don't have a
liberal
pluralistic
democracy.
Okay.
Let's not--
and this gets to Miroslav's point--
let's not conceal from ourselves the fact
that acceptance of those four principles
requires a lot of-- I'll call it this-- requires a lot
of shaping up
on the part of both the state
and the religions
present in society.
Each party,
the state
and the religions,
have to refrain from doing a lot of what they
have historically done.
Now fortunately, at the time of the American
founding,
most of this shaping up
had already occurred or was about to occur,
in the US with respect to the state
and the religions. People were beginning to
think
along these lines, or
nobody had to
force them into thinking along these lines.
But,
to repeat,
it was historically
a radical and risky
experiment.
A state with no official religion,
a state with no official religion
in any way had never seriously been tried
before.
Now we're all aware of the fact
that many religious people around the globe
do not like this kind of democracy.
And I dare say that
many of you, probably most of you, are aware
that some of those people
are located in this country--
that is, in the United States.
The US is not
"this country" for all of you here, I'm sure.
That is to say-- let me put it more bluntly--
there are a lot of present-day American Christians
who do not like liberal democracy,
that phase of it I've described.
That was clear from
the Howard West quotation.
A good many Christian leaders, including some
theologians, have what I can only think
of as an extremely sour
attitude towards liberal democracy.
Now, a number of reasons for that, as you'd expect,
but if I hear correctly, there is one common
theme running through those in this country
and abroad.
And that thing is this:
once upon a time
the state was the highest expression,
or one of the two highest expressions,
of the religion-moral unity of a people.
Here's
where their
religious moral unity came to its topmost
institutional expression.
A liberal
democratic society is committed to its not
being that.
That is, it's not giving expression to one particular
religious party.
It's committed to being no more than an arrangement
of convenience, so it's said,
whereby a number of such distinct communities can live together.
But it itself
is a-
religious.
It's a-moral.
An arrangement of convenience for such communities.
And--
okay, here's the real point--
and
thereby it forces a dichotomy into the
lives of religious people.
It forces them to divorce their religion from
their politics.
The Muslims who live in this country cannot live by sharia;
they can't.
And you can fill out the counterpart for any other religion
you want.
One of the most influential twentieth-century Muslim writers-- I'm going to mispronounce his
name, I'm sure, so you can tell--
those of you who know how to pronounce it
will tell me afterwards-- Sayyid Qutb--
an Egyptian intellectual who was executed by the Egyptian government in
nineteen sixty-six.
Qutb had lived for a time in the US, out
in Colorado,
and had found American life abhorrent.
In the lives of America there is what he called-
marvelous phrase--
"a hideous schizophrenia."
A hideous schizophrenia
between religion and life.
And he thought this "hideous schizophrenia,"
had its origins in original Christianity,
where he thought that Jesus had spiritualized the
Jewish religion.
And he thought that
liberal democracy,
by its very structure,
expressed
and reinforced
this hideous
schizophrenia.
It forced the privatization of religion.
And if the four principles that I cited
are indeed basic structural principles of
liberal democracy,
then
in a structural sort of way,
he's right about that.
That kind of shaping up
of religions
required
by the very structure of the liberal democracy.
So pull it together like this: if religious people
have good reasons
for supporting
liberal pluralistic democracy,
those reasons will have to support those four
principles and the
kind of division
that I mentioned.
Now, I think that some religious people
do have
good reasons for supporting those four principles.
To speak for myself, I think Christianity provides such reasons, though
there are a lot of my fellow Christians
who disagree.
Now, I said I was going to talk about both
questions, but I've really almost eaten up
my time. So what do you think, Miroslav? Should I just
cut off what I have to say about
religious reasons in
liberal democracy?
VOLF [off-camera]: No.
[Laughter.]
VOLF [off-camera]: Otherwise it would remain a secret.
Okay, so now the second question. So my citation
of those four principles may well have left
you thinking,
as it did Qutb,
that there just isn't any place for religious
reasons in public debate in a
democracy.
You may have concluded that the
principles, those four principles rule it out.
And quite a few writers in recent years
have made that inference-- that the very idea
of a liberal democracy rules out the use of
religious reasons in public debate.
But I think that's a mistake.
But government in the ways I mentioned
has to be impartial in its treatment of citizens
with respect to the religion or their lack thereof.
I think that does not imply
excluding
religious reasons,
it excludes thinking religiously about
political topics, and speaking of them.
Now in your reading for today
there are some pieces that introduce you to
that debate that's been going on for two decades--
whether--
so you know the basic issues.
I'm not going to
dabble into all of them, but I think it may be
helpful to bring these two topics together
if I briefly review why John Rawls thought it was
one of the principles of liberal democracy
that citizens should use what he calls
public reasons, and not
religious reasons, in public debate.
So this will sort of tie the two together, okay? Rawls.
I talked about
the structural features-- four of the structural
features of a liberal democracy.
Rawls-- Rawls was of the view-- and
I share this view--
Rawls was of the view that behind these structural
principles,
there's a certain cluster of ideas
about how citizens are to treat each other.
And that the structure
is an expression of these
background
implicit
ideas as to how we should treat each other.
These background ideas make sense of the
structure.
It's not just a
happenstance.
And, Rawls thought then--
obviously--
that citizens who really believe in liberal
democracy,
as opposed to just
putting up with it,
implicitly accept these
background explanatory principles.
They don't have them at the top of their hands, it's implicit--
but they're implicitly
accepting it
if they agree with liberal democracy instead
of
just putting up with it.
Here's one of those
important implicit
background principles for Rawls's thought:
"We are to treat each other as free and equal."
Fundamental
explanatory background principle to treat--
citizens are to treat each other as free and
equal. Okay?
So now, says Rawls, ask yourself this question:
what does that principle--
treating each other as free and equal--
what does that principle imply
for how we debate
and decide political issues?
What does the free and equal principle imply
for how we conduct our debates?
And here's Rawls's answer:
at least when it comes to important issues
of justice,
we should stand ready to appeal to principles
that we can expect all of our fellow citizens
to share.
Or at least all who
sincerely believe in liberal democracy-- the
others may not, sure--
we should appeal to principles that we can
expect
all the believers-- our fellow believers in liberal
democracy-- to share.
Otherwise-- here's Rawls's thought--
if we just go ahead and vote our own
view,
we're imposing our views on the others and
not treating them
as equal.
I'm saying, "I know better than you
what the laws of this land should be like.
I'm not treating you as
a co-author of the laws."
It should be obvious at a glance that that
principle eliminates the use of religious
reasons,
because you-- one thing you can be absolutely
sure of: any religious reason that you can
devise is is not going to be shared by some
of your present-day fellow Americans, right? Okay.
So where do we find the shared reasons?
And Rawls's ingenious--
I think that it was a boot-strapping suggestion--
Rawls's ingenious suggestion was this:
here's where you can find the principles--
look back once again at those principles
implicit in liberal democracy
that we got this first one from-- treating everybody
as free and equal.
Look back at the other implicit principles.
Everybody who accepts liberal democracy
believes those, right? So that's going to be our--
body of our shared principles.
That's what he called public reason.
It's going to take some work
to dig 'em out, they're implicit--
that's what political philosophers are for
and so forth--
but that's what we should appeal to.
It won't matter, says Rawls, if people, if religious people add on some religious reasons.
I don't want matter for debating minor matters.
My memory of being in New Haven is that always
by Thanksgiving there is a great big
tree-- Christmas tree on the Green, and there's
not this year, so New Haven must have
had a
dispute about that.
And Rawls would say, "They don't have to avoid
using religious reasons to settle-- I mean it's
unlike it-- well, somebody might--
you know, no big deal--
Huh?
Yeah, there, that's what I expected.
So, let me talk to a conclusion.
I'm not going to rehearse my reasons for thinking
that this proposal, ingenious and interesting
as it is, doesn't work.
It's my impression that the state of the debate
over this now
is that-- it's widely agreed--
that those who are opposed to using religious reasons
in public debate have not succeeded in making
their case.
So here's
my own view, briefly presented.
With two crucial implications-- sorry, two crucial
qualifications--
my view is this:
I think it's okay for citizens to use whatever
reasons
that they themselves have for their political
views,
or whatever reasons they find cogent.
Rarely if ever does it happen that consensus
emerges.
So I think a crucial part of liberal democracy
is a fair vote.
And I find it's
endlessly curious that Rawls and Audi and Lorimer and so forth-- Habermas--
say almost nothing about vote.
I think we almost never achieve consensus, so we
have to have a fair vote.
Here are the two qualifications:
the entire debate takes place within the framework
of a constitution.
Some proposals are just off the table,
or they're so hard to get onto the table
that they may just as well be off the table.
That's our great-- that's the great protection
in a liberal democracy against the rule--
oppressive rule of the majority.
There's a constitution which says,
"These things can't be done!"
Second, I've come to think that the
character of the debate is important-- how the
debate is conducted--
not so much its content, but how it's conducted.
Citizens are to treat each other civilly.
Become informed,
be willing to present their reasons to others,
be willing to listen to the reasons of others.
Let me just say parenthetically
that one of my great--
what word do I--
sorrows, laments, whatever,
is that American political dialogue is so un-civil, it is so chock full
of people demeaning their fellow citizens.
Whatever be their reasons.
They should never demean their fellow citizens.
So I think the debate over
whether religious reasons are acceptable
was an important debate to have,
but I think the real discussion now has to be over
"And how should we conduct that debate so that we
treat our fellow citizens with dignity
and honor, and justice. And respect."